this box has been in my cupboard a long
time though this box is much older than
most of the other stuff because I
brought this when there was a schoolboy
and it is travel round with me in this
box there are some souvenirs of my
grandfather the discharge is because
they are tubes for electrical discharge
I'll just show you this one because it
stands up you can see it's a piece of
quite ornate glassware and if you look
there are a number of features that you
can see it has been sealed off here and
here by putting a torch so it was sealed
with a vacuum or gas in it and there's a
narrow tube going inside which goes
round and round around and so on and
then there used to be an electrode at
the top now there's just a bit of wire
and there is an electrode at the front
this is an example of what is called a
Geissler tube named after German
physicist Paul Gessler who invented this
in 1857 he belonged with the other two -
my grandfather my grandfather who was
called Joseph Polyakov was an
extraordinarily talented inventor he had
I don't know how many patents in his
lifetime he invented the volume control
which is now on every radio he invented
the hearing loop which helps deaf people
hear in concert halls and so on and lots
of other things as well he also invented
an early form of the transistor in the
1920s but why he had these I don't know
I think he probably just thought they
were fun and if you look at the glass
the glass is slightly yellow because
it's impregnated with some sort of iron
which fluoresces when exposed to UV
light the point about these guys the
tubes is that they're filled with a low
pressure of gas unfortunately I don't
know which sort of gas it's definitely
not neon because neon would blow red it
may be air it could be air with the
trace of mercury but the important thing
about
these gases are that when you apply a
high voltage
Emile used a device called the Tesla
coil named after the famous scientist
Tesla which produces a very high voltage
at a very high frequency it's
sufficiently high that it can jump
across narrow gaps of insulators like
air and what is to me even now
remarkable is that if you applied them
to these you get a discharge you
generate a plasma in the gas without
having to have any electrical connection
to the other electrode presumably there
is enough current that will leak either
through the glass or to earth through
the air the mechanism is the
high-voltage ionizes the gas the ions
recombine and give out energy this makes
the gas hot and it emits light not
necessarily just because it's hot but
because the electron as it falls back to
the nucleus or to the energy levels
which it normally occupies gives out
light so it's a way of generating light
right and the particular gas will give a
particular wavelength of light I don't
know what this is
maybe air even and the reason I don't
know get a characteristic discharge from
a gas which depends on the identity of
the gas and the pressure and since we
don't know the pressure and we don't
know the gas it's a bit difficult to
guess there are measurements we might be
able to do but we might damage the tubes
and anyway we don't have the kit at the
moment this equipment must be quite old
because my grandfather if he was still
alive would be a hundred and forty-three
years old and he died fifty five years
ago so the very minimum is probably 70
or 80 years old could be a hundred years
old so the gas has been sealed inside
the gas for that time and the fact that
they still work means they're still at
low pressure and air has not gone inside
the tube from outside everything leaks
slightly but the rate of leakage
is so slow that the performance has not
been affected and I find that pretty
remarkable the other thing which you can
tell is that because the glass and the
liquid here glow when the discharge
takes place it means that the gas is
emitting UV light so presumably the tube
going through here is either glass that
does not absorb UV light very strongly
it could be quite thin glass or it may
even be quartz there if it's quartz it's
a fantastic piece of glass blowing
because quartz is not an easy material
to blow I have once tried using this I
can't remember when when we used to have
Tesla coils in the lab but I haven't
used it for 20 or 30 years at the
minimum but then I thought that Neil
would like to get his hands on it and I
wasn't wrong what to me is remarkable is
that these pieces of equipment which are
made purely for entertainment
they have no deep scientific value and
were made to entertain audiences perhaps
a hundred years ago are still working
today and are still entertaining the
people perhaps entertaining you
definitely entertaining me but also
posed intriguing questions what is the
liquid what is the glass made of and so
on and of course what immediately comes
to mind is what techniques you could
find to identify these things without
damaging the equipment
I think that my grandfather would be
quite amused
I knew him though he died when I was 11
but I think he would be very amused that
it was being shown to such a big
audience he couldn't possibly have
imagined the number of people that would
watch this video even if it's not very
successful we're talking about thousands
of people watching it and so I think it
is really quite a a tribute to my
grandfather that the items that he
collected are now being shared with the
big audience